MARTIN OMANDER: Hi, Derek.
DEREK DOWNEY: Hi, Martin.
MARTIN OMANDER:
So, Derek, you are
a developer advocate
specializing in databases,
right?
DEREK DOWNEY:
Yeah, that's right.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
I have a question
from a customer who
is building the product on
top of Google Cloud using
serverless products and they
need a relational database
for their application.
DEREK DOWNEY: Sure,
happy to help.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN OMANDER: The customer
is building a system
using Cloud Run, and
they picked Cloud Run
so they don't have to
provision and maintain servers.
And this reduces
the ops work needed
to keep the system running.
Initially, they picked
a NoSQL database
that helped them get their MVP
out the door really quickly.
DEREK DOWNEY: That makes sense.
MARTIN OMANDER: They got
great feedback from customers
for version 1 of their
system and they're
getting ready for version 2.
They realized they will need
ACID transactions and also
aggregations, like
sums and averages,
across thousands of records
from their database.
And they can't do that easily
in their NoSQL database.
DEREK DOWNEY: Got it.
Any particular issues
they're trying to solve
with ACID transactions?
MARTIN OMANDER:
Yeah, they've been
having consistency issues with
the data as more customers use
their app.
And they're spending a lot
of time fixing those issues.
DEREK DOWNEY: Ah-ha, Yes.
OK, do they have any
other requirements?
MARTIN OMANDER: Well, they
want a managed database
that scales as they grow.
And they want to minimize
the ops work needed
to keep the system running.
DEREK DOWNEY:
Well, in that case,
they should look
at Cloud Spanner.
It's a fully-managed
relational database
that ensures strong consistency
and great availability.
And it has unlimited
scalability,
so it will easily scale
as their needs grow.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right,
Derek, let's break that down.
You started out
saying fully managed.
What kind of ops
work would they need
to do to keep their
Spanner running smoothly?
DEREK DOWNEY:
Well, for starters,
they don't have to
worry about patching
or other typical
server maintenance.
They also don't have to manage
any complex architectures
for load balancing or failovers.
They don't even have
to manage encryption,
though Spanner has the
option for the customers
to manage encryption
keys if they require it.
They will have to
manage access control
and schedule their own backups.
They're also in charge
of schema migrations,
but Spanner manages the
deployment of those changes.
Schema changes in Spanner
are online, though,
so they won't block the
app during the migration.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
And, next, you said
unlimited scalability.
That's a pretty
bold claim, Derek.
DEREK DOWNEY: Yeah.
Spanner provides
consistent transactions,
like other relational databases,
and is a horizontally scaling
database similar
to NoSQL databases.
So it grows with your data.
To give you an idea,
Spanner processes
over 1 billion requests
per second at peak.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Wow, that's a lot.
Then you said
strong consistency.
How can a global
relational database
be strongly consistent?
DEREK DOWNEY: Great question.
Spanner relies on TrueTime
to provide commit timestamps
to guarantee global consistency.
TrueTime is an
internal Google service
that guarantees monotonically
increasing timestamps
with microsecond granularity
across all nodes.
These timestamps,
combined with Google's
dedicated infrastructure,
allows Spanner
to be strongly consistent
at low latencies.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
And, finally, you said
great availability.
What does that mean
in this context?
DEREK DOWNEY: Spanner
comes with an SLA guarantee
of up to five nines
of availability
to ensure users have
access to their data.
Spanner stores multiple copies
of your data in different zones
or regions to handle
maintenance and outages.
This is transparent
to your application,
so your code doesn't need to
know where the replicas are.
MARTIN OMANDER: It
sounds like Spanner
fits the needs of the customer.
Could we take it for a spin?
DEREK DOWNEY: Yeah.
What did you have in mind?
MARTIN OMANDER: My test
app is a simple REST
API for managing users.
I'm thinking I'll swap out its
NoSQL database with Spanner
to get a feel for how
much work it would
take to migrate a real project.
DEREK DOWNEY: We
can totally do that.
First, go to the Cloud Console.
Click the hamburger
menu and scroll down
to the Databases section
and click Cloud Spanner.
Then click Create Instance.
MARTIN OMANDER: Mhm.
OK, I did.
Aha.
I see a lot of options here.
What should I pick?
DEREK DOWNEY: If all of your
users are in a single region,
you'd want a single
region configuration
to minimize latency.
If the database will be
accessed from multiple regions
or you need five nines of
availability guarantees,
you'd want the
multiregion configuration.
MARTIN OMANDER: Let's use
a regional configuration.
And I see that the
price changes up here
as I change the options.
Do I need a full node?
DEREK DOWNEY: Probably not yet.
To get started, you'd
probably want to go smaller.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
For now, I'll set
up a dev environment
with 100 processing
units, which will come out
to $0.09 per hour or
about $65 per month.
DEREK DOWNEY: Good idea.
They can always scale
that instance up later
without any downtime.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right,
I'll click Create here.
Now I assume my code will need
to change to access Spanner.
DEREK DOWNEY: Yeah.
I sent you some code before.
Did you get it?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yep,
I'm pasting it in now.
DEREK DOWNEY: Spanner
provides client libraries
for many languages,
including Node.js.
Since our application is
Node, all we have to do
is require the library,
instantiate the Spanner class,
and then provide the instance
and database information.
We could tune how session
pooling is handled,
but the defaults are a
great starting point.
Accessing the data is
done with standard SQL.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Does my code need
to specify which Spanner
replica or region to hit?
DEREK DOWNEY: No, Spanner
handles that for you.
All you need to specify is
the instance and database.
If Cloud Run is configured
with a service account that
can work with Spanner,
you don't even
have to provide credentials.
Otherwise, you can
provide those, too.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right, I'm
deploying my updated Cloud Run
service now.
Looks like the API
is still working.
So what kind of
loads can it handle?
DEREK DOWNEY: I
set up a load test
that hits our test
application at roughly
3-to-1 reads to write,
which is the observed
pattern from production.
I'll start with 32
concurrent users.
Let's see what happens.
MARTIN OMANDER: Looks
like a decent amount
of operations per second here.
DEREK DOWNEY: Yes.
Now let's look at the CPU
to see how it's holding up.
MARTIN OMANDER: Mhm.
It looks like a load is
crossing the recommended CPU
threshold here.
What do we do?
DEREK DOWNEY: Right.
If it goes much
beyond that threshold,
you would see request
latencies increase.
We don't want that.
We can just increase
the processing units.
Let's do that now.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
It looks like the CPU is
having an easier time now.
And in Locust, we're able
to handle many more requests
per second than before.
Those extra units really helped.
Pretty impressive for a globally
consistent relational database
with ACID transactions.
Nice that you can tweak
capacity while the database is
under load.
Yeah, and there are no changes
to the application needed.
Great.
The customer will
get ACID transactions
in a managed database
with Spanner.
They can start
small and scale up
without users being impacted
Thanks for showing me
how to do this, Derek.
DEREK DOWNEY: You're
welcome, Martin.
I think Spanner would work
well for the next version
of the customer's system.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Yeah, I think so.
Thank you, everyone,
for watching.
If you have questions for
me or Derek about Spanner,
please enter them in
the comments below.
Also let us know in the
comments if you have suggestions
for other serverless topics we
should bring up on the show.
Bye for now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]